this is a landscape and a livelihood
transformed
the withered vines now a painful
reminder of what fire delivered to this
island
and is everything destroyed in terms of
the vineyards
in terms of the vineyards
i think everything is pretty much
destroyed two generations of jason
zafierokopoulos's family
have managed this winery but the intense
weather of recent days has set
all their progress back we're thankful
that we still have our home and
our buildings for our business because
the flames came so very close
that we might have been homeless today
so i guess we're thankful for that
but we do struggle to figure out how
we're going to
recover large swathes of roads have
burned during days of fires on the
island
the worst blazes many residents who've
lived here for years have ever seen
there has been no respite for the rescue
services as one blaze is put out
another ignites very high temperatures
and strong winds have created a toxic
mix on this island what is the worst
heat wave in greece for over 30 years
brought ministers to roads
officials keen to see the work of the
emergency services
and to deliver a stark warning as to why
they think extremes of weather
are occurring it's directly to climate
change
yes and as you see the temperatures that
greece is experiencing
are quite high but it's not only that we
see these temperatures in north america
all over the world australia we see
wildfires
burning uh millions of acres
and concerns about rising temperatures
could impact industry on this island
which relies heavily on tourism
the visitors may come for the sun but
the heat of recent days has proved too
much for some
what if things got even hotter in years
to come
no it was not good not good a little bit
too hard
to be honest but yeah it makes us think
also about the
environment a little bit we'd probably
just come at a different time of year
like
october or something they have ways of
uh how to cope with it i wouldn't care
that much
but yeah it's it's getting a little bit
unbearable
one way to cope of course is with air
conditioning but people have been asked
to use it as little as possible in this
heat
to conserve energy supplies damaged by
the fires
michelle clifford sky news roads